in the words of the Joker from The Dark
Knight trailer where do we begin
[Music]
transformers the last night
so transformers the last night is
another Transformers bus fire
monstrosity directed by Michael Bay it's
really fair to this one man but there's
so much [ __ ] that happens in this movie
so much nonsense I'm not going to hit
all of it all the [ __ ] that I drive
about trust me there is more basically
transformers keep coming to earth now
big bet evil transformers planet is
coming for Earth Optimus Prime's been
reprogrammed or brainwashed point is
he's bad don't worry not on screens that
much so you don't have to worry about it
and bad jokes awkward dialogue Mark
Wahlberg hasn't saved the day from the
get-go it's back in the Dark Ages
because you know there's ooh secrets of
the past and at first I was like all
right this looks like it could be up the
dialogue started and attempts at humor
and it's awkward and weird it's not
funny it's just Michael Bay isms and now
you know you're just you're in for a
ride in which you just have to survive
this nothing makes sense man just
totally speaking the world in this movie
contradicts itself at first you hear a
voiceover transformers keep falling out
of the sky or is everywhere they fight
everywhere they're just destroying [ __ ]
you did it scene in the trailer it's
also in the movie where this busted-up
stadium all because of them there's even
these new government agencies that deal
with transformers because they're all
bad in the eyes of the people I feel
like things are shitty everywhere
because when a hundred percent of human
beings are concentrating on this
invasion that's happening on our planet
yet when TVs are on you still see things
like Indy 500s happening rich people
still play polo you feel like just
contradictory information sometimes the
movie wants you to feel like it's just
all encompassing there are transformers
everywhere it literally has changed the
living conditions of our world other
times the world feels no different than
our worlds weird speaking of awkward
Michael Bay humor is in it like there's
this guy like this big huge planetary
thing is coming after our world his
other dudes like I sounds like nerd [ __ ]
to me I'm like you do know you live in a
world where the movie told us that
robots are coming here at an exponential
rate why is that so unbelievable like
why is that weird if this was the time
of transformers 1y I would expect some
disbelief as it stands I feel like
information like that would be about as
believable as there's a Wal Mart down
the road oh [ __ ] no kidding all right
now I know shortly into this movie it
concentrates on Mark Wahlberg he runs
this junk shop where he had some
Autobots and it's just awkward humor and
awkward humor more awkward humor is
painful it felt like this scene was
going on for a half an hour great I know
it probably wasn't but damn it it felt
like it in the end it's how long a scene
feels not how long it actually is if it
scene feels like a half an hour it's
only five or ten minutes guess what to
the person watching it's a half an hour
it's not funny it's not cleverest doing
nothing for the characters nothing for
the plot it's just a time scene and
there's little girls there is a little
girl from the trailer like I want to
fight them she's like 14 years old and
by the end of the movie you're like what
did you do for the movie that why are
you here didn't do anything she's even
in the last act of the movie that's just
a bunch of explosions in action and
things are happening she's death a lot
of action death and she's there for it
she's there for it because of the John
Goodman robot with the cigar from the
last movie she asked him like can I go
with you he's like yeah sure let's take
a field trip to the frontlines kid even
the main girl in this movie super
educated historian you can tell Michael
Bay's like really good at titty and ass
shots by 2017 we live in a progressive
world so I have to make the girl smart
and actually I have to make her do [ __ ]
I'll try those of you looking forward to
Optimus Prime he shows up at the end of
the movie yeah he's on the poster
composer a lot more than he is in the
movie reminded me of Transformers
Revenge of the Fallen Optimus Prime was
not in the movie for the majority of it
I did like the Josh Duhamel thing he's
in this movie too he's in the first
couple Transformers movies but he's a
government guys a military guy and the
government the military really like laws
are all bad in our eyes I like the fact
that he's like I've worked with them but
I have a job to do that's a good
conflict but not well-executed this
movie's two and a half hours long if you
cut out all the cheesy as corny awkward
ass dialogue moments among human beings
that no one gives a [ __ ] about because
it's called transformers have yourself a
two hour movie that's still not great
but better and this is an unusual
complaint of mine but it's a complaint
of mine the aspect ratio kept changing
it was really weird you know some of is
like Christopher Nolan does this a lot
where he'll filming action sequences in
IMAX so for that action sequence is boom
the aspect ratio goes from the scope
aspect ratio that looks like this an
action sequence but fills up the whole
frame of the iMac when the action
sequence is done goes back to scope this
one the action sequences did that but
they would switch back to scope and then
go back to IMAX in scope and an iMac
it was really odd but it wasn't like
after the scene was done it was woven
within the scene itself this shots were
different aspect ratios in this scene it
was really jarring it was like a right
action sequence the aspect ratio looks
like this we're going to get some
Transformers you ready I'm ready let's
do it the kids in Transformers all right
book my action sequence I'm shoot you're
taking fire I got your back it's like
these scenes were filmed with four
cameras two of which were IMAX cameras
the other two were normal digital
cameras and somehow a successful
director thought it would be what
unnoticeable just film the scenes with
different cameras no one will notice now
you're not going to be able to unsee it
I feel kind of bad about that frankly
not everyone's going to find that
jarring but I used to be a
projectionists aspect ratios they jump
out at me so it was really noticeable it
was like why is it happening like that
basically in a nutshell this movie is
just too jarring it tries to set up so
much is cluttered when it starts this is
the movie goes on it's cluttered in a
different way it's no longer set up it's
just biller it's cluttered filler then
the movie goes on with half of the
unnecessary characters and then
introduces half of the other unnecessary
characters and again with more cluttered
filler means that's what the movie
should be called transformers of the
cluttered filler in the last act of the
movie happens and there's so much [ __ ]
happening you're like wait where are
they right now a lot of [ __ ] happens and
then it ends as abruptly as any
Transformers movie does Michael Bay says
this is his last Transformers movie I
genuinely hope it is the Transformers
story could be a good one but it's just
done by a director who I don't think
gives a [ __ ] the movie is too cluttered
it concentrates on all the wrong stuff
the dialogues not funny half the
characters you're like why are you in
here what did you do the little girl is
useless the humor didn't land it just is
so painfully awkward when a joke has a
pause after the joke so people in the
theater can laugh so they're not missing
any dialogue after that but no one
laughs it's really awkward it is
basically every Michael Bay is in
transgression that Michael Bay has done
in the previous Transformers movies that
are gripes in the previous Transformers
movies double down for this one I don't
get why like I said I'm sure there's
more but my brains like get the [ __ ] I'm
forgetting the movie as I'm talking
about it because in the end transformers
the last night hopefully is the last of
the dog [ __ ] uh here's hoping man here's
open Michael Bay actually sticks to his
word alright guys so transformers though
last night have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
and least favorite Transformers movie
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]